seit letzter nacht überqueren türkische
truppen und hunderte syrische arabische
freischärler die von der türkischen
armee ausgebildet und ausgerüstet wurden
die grenze bei attac unterstützt von
großflächigen artillerie- und luft
bombardiert stoßen sie in das kurdische
haltet in nordsyrien vor angegriffen
wurde dabei heute auch kamishli die
bevölkerungsreichste syrische stadt im
osten der syrisch-türkischen grenze
wir haben zehn notfälle zwei von ihnen
sind in einem kritischen zustand
bislang sind nach syrischen angaben 30
menschen getötet worden mehr als 60.000
zivilisten fliehen aus angst vor den
bomben aus den ortschaften an der grenze
ins landesinnere staatspräsident erdogan
lobte vor parteifunktionären den ankara
heute die quelle des friedens genannte
offensive bei der schon mehr als 100
terroristen ausgeschaltet worden seien
sagte er
unter drohte europa wenn wir versucht
unsere operation als invasion
darzustellen werden wir die türen öffnen
und 3,6 millionen flüchtlinge zu
schicken
bei den kämpfen feierten kurdische
milizen aus syrien granaten auf das
türkische aktie ab dabei gab es nach
türkischen angaben zwei tote und mehrere
verletzte
die türkische justiz hat unterdessen
gegen dutzende journalisten politiker
und internetnutzer ermittlungen wegen
terror propaganda eingeleitet weil sie
den einmarsch nach syrien kritisiert
hatten
[Applaus]